The case of Hill v Jones deals with the question of when parties have an
affirmative duty to disclose information during contract negotiations,
the hills had purchased the Jones's house when it turned out to be infested with
termites.
They sued to rescind the contract for sale.
Let's consider what happened in the case in chronological order in 1963 under
earlier owners,
the house received its first treatment for termites from truly Nolan.
Nolan then gave the owner's termite guarantees which entitled them to semi
annual inspection.
There's an annual termite booster treatments.
When the Joneses subsequently bought the house in 1974 they renewed these
guarantees and continued pain,
Nolan annual fees for inspection and treatment as well as diagrams as where in
the house there had been termite damage during their ownership.
There was additional evidence of infestation including streamers in the wood
tile floor near the entryway and truly Nolan came back and treated the house and
fence.
Fast forward to 1982 and the Joneses or selling the house,
the hills are attracted to it because of the parquet floors,
but they notice a ripple in the wood.
When Mr. Hill asks whether the ripple is termite damage,
Mrs. Jones says that it is water damage.
They enter into an agreement for the hills to buy the house dependent on the
results of the termite inspection.
The Joneses,
however,
do not give the termite inspector the information they have about the past
termite damage.
And so he does not notice that the house is infested,
is infested.
In part,
this may be because of strategically placed boxes and plants that hide all
evidence of the past.
Termite treatments holes in the patio and the like after the they move in the
hills discovered a serious infestation in the house,
which would cost them $5,000 to repair.
And keep in mind that at the time the whole house costs $72,000 the hill sued
the Joneses for rescission of the contract,
arguing that the termite report was fraudulent because of the Jones,
his misrepresentations.
We're reading the case on appeal at the court of Appeals of Arizona.
The trial court ruled for the defendants sellers on a summary Judgment motion.
So keep in mind that the key question here is was there a genuine question of
fact that should have gone before a jury?
There are two key questions.
First,
does the integration clause in the contract prevent the court from the Jones is
silence and second,
did the defendant have a duty to disclose the possibility of termite
infestation?
Judge Meyerson disposes of the first question very briefly.
He writes that quote where a misrepresentation is fraudulent or where a
negligent misrepresentation is one of material fact.
The policy of finality rightly gives way to the policy of promoting honest
dealings between the parties will be studying more about integration or
sometimes they're called merger clauses later in the course when we study the
parole evidence rule integration clauses sometimes stop courts from looking
beyond the four corners of a written contract,
but for now it's enough to know that because this case can turns the possibility
of intentional fraud.
The integration,
the integration clause does not prevent the court from looking into the parties
dealings.
It would be unjust to strictly enforce the policy favoring finality.
Judge Meyerson spends more time discussing the context in which silence on the
part of a seller is not acceptable.
Section one 61 of the second restatement of contracts lists the four main
exceptions to the general common law rule that parties do not have an obligation
to speak during negotiations.
The first exception is when disclosure is necessary to prevent a previous
assertion from being a misrepresentation or from being fraudulent or material.
In particular,
the judge is worried about situations when one conveys a false impression by the
disclosure of some facts and the concealment of others.
This can constitute false representation.
This could conceivably be the case here.
When Mrs. Jones is said that what looked like termite damage was in fact water
damage,
the hills might reasonably take that statement to mean that there had not been
any termite damage to the house,
even though the statement is not literally falls in and of itself.
It might carry with it a false implication if that were in fact the case,
the Jones is would be obligated to conceal to correct that inference.
You should be able to see the similarity between this case and Laidlaw.
In both cases,
the asking of a question may have triggered duties of disclosure.
The second exception is the broadest and the most commonly invoked.
It requires disclosure when one party knows that the others agreement to a
contract is based on a mistake and where nondisclosure would not be in
accordance with principles of good faith and fair dealing as with the doctrines
of mutual and unilateral mistake being mistaken as to a basic assumption
triggers additional contract scrutiny.
Judge Meyerson discusses how different courts have fleshed out this requirement
in different ways and ends up adopting the Florida Supreme Court's language.
That quote where the seller of a home knows of facts materially affecting the
value of the property which are not readily observable and are known to the
buyer and and are not known to the buyer.
The seller is under a duty to disclose them to the buyer.
This could certainly be found to apply in cases like this one where those facts
concern past termite infestations.
Another way to think about this issue is in terms of implicit default
representations,
a jury might find that when sellers don't mention termite infestations,
they are by default representing that house has no termite infestations.
The buyer could then reasonably rely on that implied representation and the
seller would have a duty to disclose termite infestations to contract around the
default.
Based on these first two categorical exceptions,
Judge Myers and found that there was enough evidence that the trial court should
let a jury decide whether the information about past infestations was material,
whether the Joneses had misrepresented it and whether the hills had relied on
it.
The third exception deals with mistakes as to the contents of writings,
I.
E.
The actual written contract as opposed to facts about the world.
If one party knows that the other is mistaken about what is actually written in
the contract,
that party must correct the other party's mistake and the final exception deals
with relationships of trust and confidence where one party has a duty to act and
the other's best interest or not to use certain information that that party has
disclosed to them.
That party hat has to disclose material information.
Academics have come up with a number of theories to count for what types of
information parties ought to be obligated to disclose.
We'll discuss two of the most prominent ones in discussing Laidlaw.
We've already mentioned Anthony Kronman distinction between deliberately
acquired information and casually acquired information.
Kronman was concerned about the ex ante effects of disclosure rules on party's
willingness to gather information.
We should be reluctant to mandate disclosure of deliberately acquired
information because then parties may be unwilling to go to the expense of
gathering it knowing that they must then disclose it.
On the other hand,
mandated disclosure will have no impact on casually acquired information which
disclosing parties will continue to come to know regardless of whether they have
to disclose it.
I've suggested that car dealerships should be forced to disclose their markups
on new cars because they casually acquire this information.
The difference between the proposed selling price and what the dealer paid for
the car.
One way that the law responds to the Kronman concerned about deliberately
acquired information is to require that a party disclose what she knew or should
have known.
Forcing disclosure of what you should have known can stop you from remaining
willfully ignorant.
For example,
it might be a good idea to have the sellers of used cars take their cars to a
mechanic before selling them to learn about mechanical problems and to hold
sellers to any problems that they knew or should have known from such a
mechanics visit.
But as shown in this slide,
the legal choices about disclosure are not simply to mandate disclosure or to
adopt a laissez faire regime where disclosure is merely optional.
Sometimes the law even prohibits,
prohibits disclosure or countenances misrepresentations by Ho by holding that
certain types of facts are as a matter of law in material and thus not subject
to liability for misrepresentation.
Robert cooter and Tom Mulan emphasize a different informational dimension.
They distinguished between productive facts and redistributive facts,
productive facts or new information that has the potential to actually create
value in contracting Ri redistributive facts.
On the other hand,
only shift gains of trade between the parties.
A buyer learning that a cow is pregnant may be productive because some buyers
might be better equipped to deal with a pregnant cow.
But a buyer learning that the seller has terminal cancer and is especially
motivated to sell is more of a redistributive fact.
It might help the buyer to negotiate a lower price,
but it doesn't enhance the mutual gains of trade.
Since only productive facts create value for society,
we only reward their acquisition and,
and shouldn't really reward the acquisition of redistributive facts.
In fact,
we might want to discourage deliberate acquisition of redistributive facts
because the cost to acquire these facts are socially wasteful.
So let's look at this quiz.
What would each of these theories say about the Jones,
his obligation to disclose in this case an a?
Would both theories say that the Joneses are obligated to disclose the
information or would Kronman say that they would be obligated but cooter and
Newland wouldn't or would cooter and Ulan say they're obligated but krodman
wouldn't?
Well,
the answer is a,
the Joneses must disclose under both theories their knowledge to the earlier
termite infestation was casually acquired.
The previous owners simply handed it to them.
They did not pay or work for it in any way,
and the information is also redistributive rather than productive.
If they had disclosed it to the hills,
that would have lowered the price,
but every dollar that the Jones loss the hills would have gained.
In general,
as we have discussed earlier,
courts use the legal notions of misrepresentation and of good faith and fair
dealing to see does this side.
Cases Like Hill v Jones parties must speak so as to avoid misrepresentation due
to their silence or their fault or the false impressions created by their
literally true representations.
Good faith and fair dealing may also require them to speak where they know that
the other party is only willing to enter into the contract based on a mistake of
material fact.
We've also learned about two useful distinctions,
the deliberately casually acquired distinction and the productive
redistributive,
uh,
informational distinction that can help us think more rigorously about the
impact of mandated disclosure in specific contexts.